the former number two at the FBI who was
recently terminated just hours before
retirement is now facing potentially
serious legal trouble chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Harridge has the
latest on that tonight could even
Catherine well thank you Bret a source
close to the matter confirms to Fox News
that the Justice Department's internal
watchdog Inspector General Michael
Horowitz made a criminal referral to the
US Attorney here in Washington DC
Horowitz and his team concluded former
Deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe lied
for x three times under oath over his
role in a media leak about the FBI's
investigation of the Clinton Foundation
about two weeks before the presidential
election key section of the inspector
general's report mirrors the language
contained in the federal statute 18 USC
a thousand and one that covers line to
federal investigators it reads in part
when mccabe told investigators in May
2017 that he did not know who authorized
the disclosure to the Wall Street
Journal it was not due to a lack of
memory in our view the evidence is
substantial that it was done knowingly
and intentionally on his book tour today
director Comey said he had no knowledge
of the referral given that the IG s
report reflects interactions that Andy
McCabe had with me and other FBI senior
executives I could well be a witness
criminal referrals are usually secret
and today the Justice Department and the
Office of the Inspector General declined
to comment the McCabe's lawyer told Fox
News the standard is low in his opinion
for this type of referral we are
confident that unless there is
inappropriate pressure from high levels
of the administration the US Attorney's
Office will conclude that it should
decline to prosecute in a separate
development to congressional sources
told Fox News the seven Comey memos
memorializing his conversations with
President Trump could be delivered to
Capitol Hill by the Justice Department
as soon as tonight after Fox News
confirmed the Republican chairman of the
House Judiciary Committee threatened to
issue a subpoena after the Justice
Department missed that deadline Brett